my brother and I start this company
Vayner media we start off 50/50 I had
all the credibility in the market I had
the money I was the guy but I still went
50-50 and I feel comfortable if AJ sat
here he would say Gary did more but
whatever happens we trust each other
enough that we'll adjust in the future
to try to make it as good as we can
about 34 years in my brother has Crohn's
disease and he has to take 12 Ines out
of his intestines he's in the hospital
and he says I want out I was like okay
at this point he says he wants out how
big is the company pretty big I had to
buy my brother out for real money
then we started a company called Vayner
Sports I got 85% of company he got 15
cuz we were going to work on trying to
make it fair but he's putting into more
Sweat Equity yeah what are you bringing
to the table at 85 and he's at 15 making
up for what happened on Vayner media